what's happening reject nation i'm here
with my buddy our shaw what up reject
nation what up reject nation you might
see him on the jaby koat channel five
years ago but i met him five weeks ago
yeah baby and we just kicked it off
johnny boy is uh in surgery out of
commission for a few days and i said
now's the time for a shot to sneak on in
here with me
i would not even wish him better no no
no he's like oh that was the time no
screw that
we've never seen the trailer for the
atom project all we know is it's the
same people who made free guy i've been
wanting to watch this movie right when i
heard that and i figured we'd get along
yeah so let's watch a movie together
let's do it full length watch as long as
we sync with the time code for the atom
project over at our patreon page become
a superior jet by checking out all the
crap we got to offer over there if you
don't want to do that at least you can
do is leave a damn like
like and then boys at prepper thank you
for helping us settle down these
highlights let's get to it
[Music]
hal jordan
uh-oh
if you don't abort right now i will
shoot you out i'm sorry to interrupt
what i'm sure is gonna be a really scary
threat but if i'm right your tracking
system is about to
crash
like a video game
oh
wow okay that's another that'll open it
up [ __ ] an audience yeah okay who are
watching on their
project
no more jokes oh i'm gonna enjoy this
who talks like that did you order like a
bully starter kid
[Laughter]
oh oh my god oh and he has an inhaler
was it ray dollar height again it's
barely been a year since we lost his
father you could show some compassion
exposition exposition good exposition if
that wasn't anything
he's twice your size everyone is twice
my size i've seen babies bigger than me
i don't understand you dad would
and he's dead
[Laughter]
it's the third time you've been
suspended for fighting i know you think
i'd be better at it by now this goes on
your permanent record do you get that do
you care about your future
he's sassy you're going on a date
it's not a date
i i don't think it's a date your dress
thinks it's a date oh it is a date i am
going on a date what am i going on can i
please stop saying date now thanks oh my
gosh this is such a smart ass
he's doing such a good ride reynolds i
don't know that's a little good
dog's name hawking hawking
like hawkins from stranger things that's
a yeah
spaceship yeah there's some real like
it's something amblin entertainment
lives about this thing
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
start scoring real quick put the bat
down josh put the bat down i'm not gonna
hurt you i promise what are you doing in
here i'm you babe where's your mother on
a date
oh with who i don't know derek derek
that's yes the guy with the um
with the mouth mullet the goatee yeah
mouthful
i'm gonna get some stuff i'm not careful
with that
stay here
he got some reflexes that's for sure if
we didn't have a clue so who he was he's
john
who is he yeah
what is his d like what's his we don't
know yet don't touch my stuff is this a
lightsaber no it's not a lightsaber
okay
oh that bullet went straight through
that's good pass wait wait bullet you
were shot yeah no actually no
no i was stabbed with a bullet
[Laughter]
what's with the lightsaber it's not a
lightsaber jesus christ adam i need you
to play it cool i know that playing it
cool isn't really your thing oh i said
his name how do you know my name you're
adam reid born february 10th do you go
to franklin middle school where you've
been suspended two maybe three times for
fighting which is ironic because you
can't fight to save
how do you know my dog's name
because i named him
huh
where are you going
this is adorable i'm like in it
you're wearing my dad's watch
that's classified but yes
dude you're so lucky you're gonna grow
up to be ryan reynolds that's amazing
yeah that's a dream right there fine can
you at least tell me how you got here
i'll show you
[Music]
she is
this is so freaking cute it is that such
a chris has a wonder yeah
i love this
if i was little i would probably watch
this movie like
every day it has an adc
bit of star man yeah this kid's a star i
had no intention of coming back to
revisit
this
jesus
[Laughter]
do you remember this
remember what this right here right now
you being here in 2022 good question you
may have just changed my whole future
honestly your future is pretty tragic
either way i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
not kidding
i'm kidding
[Laughter]
this is so freaking adorable
[Laughter]
he clearly doesn't like who he is on the
inside in a lot of ways oh my god she's
in this too i feel like we're up for one
more surprise i knew nothing about this
so this is clearly a novel or a book
right the way it's or it's a great
script but it feels like a book will you
be seeing him again no i don't know i
don't think so
he's such a he's such a dick i love this
kid hello derek you have a wonderful
mouth mullet and you must be very proud
oh my gosh adam never actually heard it
called that before
you can be a real jerk sometimes
you know that
this is why time traveled back i
mean it's a little toxic of mom to say
that to her kid
just saying he has to know just yes
i'm your mother i'll let you know
oh my god
this is like an entrepreneur
this is how your dad did it
hey grab a pile
sorry i gotta get to my room to think
about what i've done
wow
wow
call me if you need me i won't
wow
dude whatever oh [ __ ] i wonder you grew
up into me and ryan reynolds wow
i don't i don't get i don't see kids
represent like represented like that's
mark ruffalo yeah
wow this cast is stacked
dad's favorite song yeah me too
dang look at he's just
built
he is just built
he's gonna be like day i look good
[Laughter]
he's like what
i just you're
kind of ripped
[Laughter]
wait do we get a lot of girls in college
i don't
time travel exists
every conceptual idea you have about the
universe has just been thrown out the
window yet your big question is
do i get laid do i jesus
[Laughter]
why don't you wear some my dad's clothes
[Applause]
what a beautiful script she's not much
of a housekeeper hey she wakes up every
morning with a broken heart and and a
closet full of his clothes and gets
nothing from you but a fistful of crap
i'm here you know tell me about it you
know 30 years
you still get sick to your stomach every
time you remember how you treated her
now oh
boy
jesus
this is this is good dude this is a good
this is a solid ass movie
[Music]
time after time
hey guys enjoying our suspension i am
now
oh that's my spleen
i remember these little turd burpers
turd burpers he's got a big mouth i get
it point is this fight needs to happen
right now
[Laughter]
so here's what you're gonna do you're
gonna walk over there and you're gonna
raise your hands
and then you're gonna look ray
right in the eye then you're gonna drop
down your knees and punch him as hard as
you can on the private bathing suit part
i'm gonna smoke
your bananas
no no no no no no that's not what we
talked about
oh god
oh
yeah oh my god oh no chuck look we made
him cry
he was trying to lose
ah
you ever hear the expression every bully
has a bully ray
if you go near adam again i'll know i
will pull bones out of your body i will
sharpen them and i will use them to stab
little chucky over here what did i do
[Laughter]
god i hated those [ __ ]
um
this is like one of the best like kids
movies in a long time every bully has a
yeah that's my ahmershaw it's bully you
wish
those were harry potter you wish
who's this who's who
that's my wife
laura
you have a wife
no we do not have a wife anymore um oh
no thanos's daughter this is this is
babies pure love
they grow into teenagers who grow in to
be assassins of happiness thank you
thank you i'm ready for this i wish i
knew what i was doing wrong you're not
doing anything wrong
oh my god there's gonna be like a back
to the future thing isn't it no i hope
not i hope this is endearing boys always
come back for their mamas
it sounds like you're speaking from
experience
i am
you have a good mom
my best mom
oh
jesus christ
[Music]
aren't you grieving too
of course are you so tell him
i don't think he needs no you think
you're being strong for him
and the problem with acting like you
have it all together is
he believes it
maybe he needs to know let you down
it's okay if you don't
wow
that's beautiful my husband had a jacket
just like that
this is classic
he loves you
well then he knows him
he better return that jacket now it's
going to look real wow
man
what a [ __ ] amazing script
hey
hey
what are you going to say i think you're
my son
i pieced it together
it's a feeling you know
i forgot about all the
bad guys the bad guys
find him
so you came back for your wife you're
not getting into that
hey she's my wife too
somebody was hiding something
maybe she saw something that saurian
didn't want her to see we're going that
way
be ready
cool
don't you do it don't do it you want to
see something cool
that's electricity
oh awesome
what is happening
[Music]
oh my god is it her
it is her this is
so fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
we should go yep let's go come on come
on come on come on come on oh my god i
love this
damn you get a group to be ryan reynolds
and marry her and that's her new family
you've got a great life ahead of you
kids he literally has his parents now
nope
someone just died
it's like return of the jedi i'm like in
this
they're not leaving they're regrouping
we have to get off this road fast what
road it's like terminator 2 with them
someone went back and altered the time
stream so the future the jet had left
from
had already been changed
god it's like i traded my brains for
those muscles
saurian must have come back to 2018 and
given her younger self some kind of
future intel and get rid of whatever
political obstacles were keeping her
from gaining total control of the time
pressure she already had that
but did she no
no she didn't it's got a lot of
information
even if we correct the time stream
somewhere in us will be the echo of this
one
and we will find each other
oh i really hope so
i love you
that's why i know you're gonna find me
again
[Music]
[Music]
it's good to see you bud shoot em we can
fix it
by destroying time travel that's right
and how are you gonna do that what's
your plan
well i'm not gonna explain my plan to a
twelve-year-old nerd with a dealer
because i do not have a plan
[Laughter]
dad oh my god
so are you in
are you
this is so good
tell your husband to get his [ __ ] ass
out here
[Laughter]
just what do you think is like 100
family film and it's like tell your
husband
[Laughter]
man what [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
straight up
maybe she missed yeah
maybe she missed like it was a warning
shot
hang on
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my god independence day this movie
has everything
the hottest night club is
this movie
did you just turn the plane off
yes i did oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
you really are the best damn pilot
we don't pull this off we're not getting
back either one of us
change your destiny
oh yeah
[Laughter]
cool
can you imagine they cast mark ruffalo
just for the photos
this movie has everything everything
everything's in it now we see professor
hulk let's go to quote the romans
enjoy yourselves
it's later than you think guy
lombardo
do i know you
just auditing the class
you're my son you're my son
i did it i figured it out didn't i
everybody everybody get out of here
something about you serious man in the
back
it's deadpool and hulk interact
adam
holy [ __ ] what he is smart dad
whoa what happened
he knows yeah can you please just shut
up for a second
for a second and listen to me
in your face
i'm just playing with the theory
that you can use wormholes for time
travel but that part's theoretical right
still theoretical this theory needs to
take a leak so let's go holy [ __ ]
i'm the godfather of time travel
stop being a scientist but i am a
scientist be a father
you're always more interested in the
universe than you were your own son
that's not true that is true and when
you're older you'll realize that
a ship is sailed it's too late for me so
you know whatever i'm fine man
it's ryan reynolds for you it's what it
is or you can get left behind in the
past hang up the phone
oh [ __ ] you hate him because he died i
think it's easier to be angry than it is
to be sad
and i guess when i get older i forget
that there's a difference do you get to
be so smart why'd you get to be so dumb
i have good news for you
he doesn't need perfect he just needs
you
you know i love you
yeah i know i'm extremely lovable
she is the best movie mom of the year
of the current times you got time
yeah
it's later than you think
she don't know what's up
[Laughter]
on your knees i won't tell you again
adam what are you doing i'm about to get
my ass kicked
i've been waiting my whole life for this
then drop down and hit him in the
private bathing suit
after that
nice work
lucky duck
that was invigorating
oh dad dad i'm sorry are you okay this
close that was amazing
hey hey
hey it's your mother's car
[Laughter]
i am so keeping this thing
no you ain't little adam feel the
vibrations kid
sorry little adam one of two things the
accelerator will continue to run on a
dormant loop or
or
there's a cataclysmic meltdown that will
destroy all living things within a
hundred miles
give me
the drive
no if i shoot him you die too
adam
i'm thinking it over
what is there to say it's a big decision
it's not a big decision i need to think
it through i'm about to lose my [ __ ]
here
[Music]
oh adam get me that drive now
okay
oh he did
[Laughter]
i want my tribe you can't have it shoot
him damn in the middle of this
do it
maya you're better than this
sorry louis but you brought this on
yourself oh no my uh ask your son how i
play
i had to kill his wife
twice
what
oh [ __ ]
damn [ __ ] i love how ryan reynolds knew
that his face was like oh
you never understood the signs
dusted
you're my boy and i love you
i love you from the first minute that i
saw you and that will never change
adam
dad
you're my boy
[Laughter]
i hate to say it but you were the best
part all along
are we gonna smoke this banana i said
play ball
[Music]
uh some really touching [ __ ] man
my throat
oh
[Music]
[Music]
but he gets to have the memories this is
how your dad did it hey grab a pile
would ya i'll be late for school oh my
gosh you're right okay have a great day
honey
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] me up right here
how you shave his beard he looks 30
years younger
he's been talking for 15 minutes managed
to put the entire class to sleep
you look awake no no no no i've trained
myself to
to fall fast asleep but keep my eyes
open
what's
[Laughter]
are you sure i mean i would hate to
disturb your sleep
i got time
clever
that's clever
yeah
this is so cute uh
damn
they did that
they did that
all their memories are going to come
back yeah
like a nightmare that hit on a lot of
real personal notes in my life oh god
damn that was really hitting me
this invited me over
to like crying for like an hour it's
just an hour and a half for traffic for
man
that was way more heartfelt than i
expected to be yeah i didn't expect
anything i thought i thought free guy
you're funny then i was like wow
had a good a lot of moments yeah a lot
of moments i had a lot of heart but then
yeah this was this is like another level
of emotion on here
it's like generational father-son
storytelling when do we talk about this
we have begun
now we'll uh
are we waiting for this to end or what
how does it i guess we're just waiting
for the credits to okay
trying to see
if they're
copying marvel so much to give us a post
credit scene all right yes we have taken
a standing break for 20 seconds and now
we are here talking
that is what is happening in the video
yeah but we are talking who we are
talking about explained it uh that was
awesome it was nice to see ryan reynolds
also bring
um
his like you know that comedy sarcasm
but do a different character at the same
time so yeah a lot more like i tried
watching the other
netflix film he did red notice have you
heard of that movie i've heard of it but
i didn't watch it i could not finish
dwayne johnson or ryan reynolds and i
and i was like i'm over this
right but this i i really i really
enjoyed his performance a lot but
i thought what was really special about
it and it and i'm sure this movie hits
the feels for a lot of people yeah and
i've expressed this before around the
time like around 2013 is when my my dad
died
so i've
was finding myself like my relationship
my dad was not like this i would say
but if on a personal level um you know
and as someone who's been in therapy for
so many years on top of that i was
appreciating all the deeper subtext of
psychology they were doing right like
when we become adults we really are just
our childhood selves as in a bigger form
right right
so like him coming to confrontation with
himself and realizing like all my
emotional [ __ ] stems from when i was
this age right now i'm dealing with that
and of course a lot of that is inherited
by the experiences he has with his
father mark ruffalo you know so you're
watching this lineage of effect and how
really the my favorite things about this
movie were the relationships and like
like some of the i like the action
scenes but some of that like big sci-fi
mumbo jumbo towards the end is like that
really wasn't like my favorite parts of
this movie yeah but actually like the
least interesting stuff like the more
subtle things with time travel but
really it was the
it was the characters the characters it
was the relationships the relationships
yeah the writing and how they changed
yeah that's what it was like the most
the writing was
phenomenal it was i can't imagine
reading that script and just being like
oh [ __ ] this is really really good
it hits
it hits like home on so many different
levels in so many different ways
um
the nostalgia was great
they had a lot of references there was
like i mean there's a lot of back to the
future some parties of like mark ruffalo
was like a doc brown situation you know
um
interacting with your mom uh
stop like fly to the navigator they yeah
i'll call out terminator at one point
you know they're star wars i feel like
they they i mean we'll get to we'll get
to that like the action but i felt like
they immediately got us with the scene
with the and the
with his mom
at the bar
yeah and you're like is this going to be
played comedy is this going to be and it
was just really sweet it was just sweet
and i was like oh man this whole movie
is going to have these like really hot
like hitting like what is it what is it
called it hits you in the feels yeah
like it really just hits you in the
fields every single one of those family
moments well i think what they did well
was like making rod rounds character
someone who's coming to
face his trauma right and how that's
just all within himself yeah putting his
younger self on a path to being a
happier better person i like that they
didn't keep the dad alive either right
that they were like that's not the point
in the movie is to save the dad the
point is how to cope with the grief
right which i thought was even more
powerful that's what i mean like there's
a lot of like there's a lot of family
messages here's so many uh and so i
really facing yourself facing yourself
is like the biggest thing yeah oh that
line the one that really started like
the one that started messing me up i
remember you reacted okay but what what
was the line it was the the one about um
you're
i know why you're upset i know why
you're angry is because he's dead yeah
how it's easy that's [ __ ] me up right
now
yeah because yeah it's easier to be
anger is usually a um a defense against
something deeper like right usually
something underneath the anger whether
that be
sadness or depression or whatever it's a
lot of times it's a defense mechanism is
what it is yeah and then so a lot of
times
it's like i remember when i was really
really little if if i had a friend or a
family member who was moving away i
would just get mad at them and i would
just treat them like crap
it's harder to deal with yeah it's
harder to deal with the sadness i'm just
mad at you now yeah
yeah but you don't you know you just
don't realize that when you're when
you're doing it it's so subconscious
yeah like oh you're not like a little
boy going i am masking my sadness with
ink you know
and so you're watching him grow up into
that so i think like i said this really
hit this hit home for you yeah i was
hitting home for me in a lot of ways and
um
and i thought like the i just thought
that all the chemistry was really good
actually everybody was so good like
young him is so good well who's this kid
walker texas ranger or something you
want her to walk or something or another
kid what is
he's phenomenal this kid was great and
he was doing such a good ryan reynolds
yeah i was like whoa
like you don't really look like him but
yeah i wonder how that was like i wonder
if there was ryan was like coaching him
on like how he would deliver stuff or if
he just like watched a bunch of ryan
reynolds stuff i think that's like it's
not even though it doesn't really look
like him what i thought was cool was
that they made sure the kid at least
i think it's first walker it captures at
least the essence of rhyme absolutely
yeah like he had he had the pentameter
of him too and like the just the
delivery good word yeah the warfighter
should just say pantameter yes what does
pentameter mean so the easiest way would
be like ionic pentameter is like
shakespeare
i'm not even gonna pretend to know that
it ends
like yeah that's like
the numbers but yeah pentameter good
good way the way that so
yeah pantameter yeah i love it
so i i felt like that kid really pulled
off like that ryan reynolds delivery and
the way he speaks and mm-hmm yeah he was
a little [ __ ] too
he's a little [ __ ] i was like he's
this
they made him mean yes he was mean and
that's what i mean is like he hates
he hates his he hates who he is on the
inside like ryan reynolds and that's it
but he was in the inside starts at a
little boy agenda right that was like so
that was like powerful that is more
powerful than a lot of people will
realize i think
yeah i didn't i yeah and yeah you know
like a lot of times i'm talking with
people or like having been like doing my
own little personal help [ __ ] has always
been like oh yeah you gotta go to those
little boy wounds
so you got to go to uproot some crap so
you can change it um
and then his relationship with even zoe
saldana while not like in it a lot yeah
she's delivered oh my god like her
chemistry around around great chemistry
yeah they were wonderful wonderful
chemistry together yeah i like instantly
bought it and for someone with that
short a screen presence yeah you need to
have that kind of instantaneous it's
gotta be good like i believe that love
yeah and that that conflicting choice of
like oh but i might sacrifice us being
together if i
if i go back and change this it had such
a potential of
getting in the realm of like a
parent trappy and it didn't yeah and it
didn't do that you know like it didn't
because you get what i'm saying like i
had that seriousness i didn't get into
the like super cheese it stayed in a
perfect family-friendly
film yeah and i was like i haven't
really watched a family-friendly film in
a long time so it was nice to like
see that especially a live action yeah
friendly one it's like the heart like
that that much of heart you know what i
mean a lot of heart yeah a lot of wonder
i thought they captured brilliant like
in terms of like it's not like
it does borrow like 80s aesthetic in a
lot of ways i think even with their
design i thought that was in the
clothing and everything about it yeah
all all the art although the way the
ships look the way they caught coloring
yeah the coloring especially even being
kind of in the woods for a lot of this
uh
like starman that i was thinking of and
so they they really captured that i do
think
i do think the villain was underwritten
i wasn't a fan of that right yeah yeah
uh i didn't find it threatening or
mentioning it's an adult i just didn't
even care though because i just loved
the family moment so much yeah i was
like the bigger [ __ ] was it was yeah
like it was just
yeah particle like celebrate where the
hell does thing go magnetic
nobody cares it started losing me a
little bit like the big finale stuff
like while it's enjoyable it it was not
the thing that is
great about the captivating at all and
it's like the villain stuff is not that
interesting it's more interesting when
they talk about
what they i mean like zoe saw donna ryan
reynolds when they're talking about
that's more interesting than actually
right coming to catherine keener and
watching her spout some generic that was
a lot of that was a lot of um
like exposition of that
part and it was just like they just
told us everything yeah you know they're
just like okay this is what's happening
rather than completely showing it but it
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter i
think i was kind of working better when
i was just kind of using my imagination
of what the future is like right but
yeah i did think that whole like big
finale thing was
i don't know i just didn't i didn't
really need something that explosive it
just wasn't like really cool even though
while there's some good moments in it
like i preferred the action scenes
earlier on like the first right the
first time in the woods
and we had a variety yeah there's a good
variety of variety and
like
those i thought were stronger than even
the big finale one right yeah but the
big finale was not like my biggest my
biggest takeaway i just like i didn't
really care for catherine keener i
didn't really like the guy who was the
bald-headed dude yeah like why do they
keep building this guy up he seems like
he sucks at what he does
he's getting his ass kicked yeah we're
giving him to act like he's the big
showdown guy right like
no not really i do like that catherine
keener kills herself in the end we're
just shooting the armor bullet right
that was a kind of uh
i
was like
yeah yeah
i i was like ah
you cared more about money than the
power science
and if only yeah yeah
that cast yeah like they're like okay
and then mark ruffalo is good
they're just like all right let's just
let's just ask
let's just keep going but who else can
we get if mark ruffalo was only if mark
ruffalo was barely in it like he was in
it pretty much the last half of the
movie yeah if he was
you see the fact that they cast mark
ruffalo
automatic because i really didn't know
anything about this movie before so the
fact that they cast mark ruffalo
made me go okay so we're definitely
going to see the dad yeah we're
definitely going to time travel at some
point to see the dad so that kind of
undercuts some of the like you're kind
of anticipating that happening yeah
whereas if they didn't cast mark ruffalo
i uh you'd just be like oh the dad's
play just actually like god yeah he's
like oh we're not doing that yeah yeah
but however
mark ruffalo was great at this movie
though so i i was happy he was here he
was awesome when they were doing the
scene uh together like the the ending
scene when it's a big touching moment of
him saying that he loves his son
when he's you know one time about google
haunting right there it was
like as i'm watching i'm like this is
[ __ ] good and then i was like i
wonder how hard it was for them to shoot
this being like so close see i actually
i did get pulled out going
with so many bloopers
yeah i literally did that yeah i did
that i was like huh
yeah i wonder how how long this took for
them to do because ryan's like crying in
it and i'm like whoa yeah like they
really i mean they're they're serious
actors but like
i i wonder how hard it was because you
always see them in like a comedy version
like this was very touching
yeah i wonder how serious they kept this
set i mean their actors who are pro
enough to be able to like still be like
yeah yeah
between takes and stuff but
yeah i did get a little pulled out
because i'm like i'm sorry you used to
see mark ruffalo doing interviews and
being a goofball yeah right reynolds
just like possibly be the goofball that
i was like they must have like ripped
each other a little bit
yeah but they brought it i was like damn
that scene was very good will hunting it
was yeah um
i would like to see ryan reynolds in
more serious roles like after watching
this i'm like
can we can we get some sort of like
oscar
type of film to do you know what i mean
i think he would kill it like he hasn't
really done all it's always like a free
guy or like a comedy or
something in a and those veins you know
i think i mean that's so the thing with
red notice was that's that's part of why
i wasn't i wasn't super into red notice
okay yeah i hadn't seen it so is that
one of the ones that's kind of like i
was serious yeah but a lot of people
like apparently it's like the most
viewed movie on netflix but it's also
like ryan reynolds being ryan reynolds
it is like
ultimate right now it's like ultimate
right right
now
i want to see him more vulnerable like
this like i like the base yeah yeah the
mixture of it all like i love his dad
like i loved him and buried and i
thought he was even like amityville
yeah buried was good he's done a lot of
he's a i think he's a really great actor
and i even think he brings variety in
free guy yeah but yeah i would like to
see him kind of do a little bit more of
these i like when you like he doesn't
have the mask on and doesn't have a mask
on you can see him actually doing the
action too right
um
but at the same time it's like as much
as this was like ryan reynolds movie it
still felt like an ensemble oh
absolutely and i think that's really
cool that like it didn't turn into
solely the ryan reynolds show when i
when it could have been i love that like
if i was a little kid i'll probably
watch this movie all the time yeah like
this is such a that like time frame of
your life that you you would watch this
over and over again so it was nice to
see that sort of film absolutely yeah
because i haven't seen that in a long
time i'm watching like
euphoria and like
crazy [ __ ] like it was nice to like come
down from this like
you know
let's watch something that's a little
bit more not
crazy in your face all the time and
shocking and you know well it's like one
of those pg-13 family films yeah it has
like peril like we just watched the
batman like
i was watching the batman and euphoria
like that's where my cinema has gone you
know like this so it's not it was nice
to see a brightly lit
film with these primary colors and being
like yeah we don't got to be all like
crazy and dark all the time i look like
yeah we do but like sometimes this is
nice i it's uh
it's cool to see a movie that literally
all ages can enjoy like yeah just like
you're not gonna be a dad or a mom who's
like i'm gonna sort of watch this for my
kid you know like my mom is gonna love
this i think i think my brother's gonna
love this this could be like an early
blockbuster for the i hope it doesn't
just fly under the radar that was great
yeah it was really good and this kid's a
star this kid's a star guys
we have done it
we have done it we have talked about the
adam project thank you so much guys for
being here thank you arshad for being
here and i'm saying thank you greg for
being you
[Music]
[Laughter]
just edit that part out for yourself
replay it just a clip
thanks for the boys and prepper check us
on patreon your support means love we'll
catch you guys soon